how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and the mcu and today it is a good day
for the mcu as we have some breaking
news miss marvel kamala khan has
officially been cast
for the upcoming miss marvel disney plus
series and this is coming to us today
from an exclusive report from
deadline.com the report reads as follows
exclusive
after a long and hard search marvel has
found its miss
marvel the studio is tapping newcomer
iman
valani to star in its disney plus series
based on the comic book character
marvel and disney plus recently named
adil l rb
and balal falal charmin obeyed chenoy
and
mira manon as directors on the project
so there you have it our kamala khan
miss marvel is going to be played by
newcomer aman valani
now amman has not been in anything at
least to my knowledge and after doing a
quick google search it doesn't look like
she has acted in a movie or
series before which means she must have
nailed her audition
kamala khan aka miss marvel is a
pakistani american teen based in new
jersey
miss marvel was marvel's first muslim
character to star in her own title and
she will become marvel studios first
on-screen
muslim hero and it has been confirmed by
marvel studios president kevin feige
that in addition to appearing on her own
show
she is going to be appearing in future
marvel films and kamala khan
will most likely go on to become a part
of the young avengers team as well
so a lot of great things happening in
the marvel universe we have shihok we
now have kamala khan
the next one up is moon knight so we can
expect that probably relatively soon but
this
is pretty crazy awesome news marvel's
first muslim hero on screen kamala khan
has officially been cast
and it will be exciting to see iman take
on the character in the series be sure
to subscribe to stay up to date on all
the latest mcu news as we are finally
getting
a lot and don't forget to subscribe so
you can enter this week's giveaway which
is a cyclops funko pop all you gotta do
is subscribe leave a comment down below
and like this video for live updates you
can follow me on twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof